[Music]
hey you guys
yeah what's up baldi me and janet
[Laughter]
i know sophie's sending me a birthday
present of uh
he said some wigs she said some wigs
it's just gonna be ridiculous that's
probably gonna be it's probably a mullet
in there
it's probably gonna be a rainbow clown
wig in there i hope so
something like that and then i said what
i needed to do what i needed to do
because she's [ __ ] with me about my
michael caine wig
because i put that [ __ ] on and forget
that i haven't all just got serious
[Laughter]
then you have this like ridiculous like
which makes it even funnier say what i
need to do is i need to [ __ ] get in
the kitchen
and make myself a tinfoil hat
[Laughter]
so whenever i whenever i start thinking
about some crazy [ __ ]
i'll i'll [ __ ] put the puts put the
tinfoil we definitely
do need a tinfoil hat for the show yeah
when i start like
theorizing behind [ __ ] paranormal
stuff
[Laughter]
or anything man [ __ ] um you know uh
globalist conspiracy theories i'll put
the title for a hat on
keep keep [ __ ] keep the fbi from
[ __ ] scanning my brain waves
yeah because i don't want to know what
i'm thinking they'll arrest me
arrest me for pre-crime and [ __ ]
like uh tom cruise movie man the little
robotic ants will come in and get me
little robotic spiders will come in and
get me
yeah i'd like to see that
so jenny and i saw this movie last night
it's a russian flick
it's called what's it deep penetration
what's it called
super duper that's the porno super duper
the porno version super super deep i've
also seen it called the super deep
yeah yeah super deep it sounds like a
[ __ ]
sounds like interracial porn doesn't it
super deep well you know it's but like i
didn't even realize this and i'll get
into like what the movie's about in a
minute but the
the uh the hole at the center of this
the whole the hole at the center of this
movie yeah is a
that's a real thing it's called the cola
super deep borehole
yeah and then i was just kind of like
[ __ ] i was like you're a borehole
super duper the cola super deep
and they started they started building
it back in 1979
and i guess in 1989 it got to its
deepest point which is more than seven
and a half miles into the earth yeah
and i was like well [ __ ] but that's what
this movie is
uh based on so i i didn't realize that
that was like a real thing what are they
doing down there
who knows yeah well hopefully not what
they're doing in this [ __ ] movie
because that would that would be bad
yeah it's pretty weird flick it
i'm not gonna say it was a bad flick it
wasn't a great flick it was good it was
passable
um i think the main thing about it was
that it was a little bit too long
yeah because it's almost two hours i
started falling asleep towards the end i
kind of felt like yeah i kind of felt
like the 30 minutes could have been
trimmed out of it yeah
um just and another thing too was that
some of the stuff like i didn't um
i didn't really get a good sense of
where they were
in the facility and how are we getting
out now are we going deeper now or was
it like i don't know if i just wasn't i
mean i was paying attention
the weird thing too is that it's a
russian movie but it's in
english and it looks like some of the
actors were dubbed although it looks
like from their mouths it looks like
they're speaking english but it kind of
sounds like they're dubbed but then the
main woman that's in it that plays anna
um i'm pretty sure that's her real voice
it didn't look like she was dubbed and
she just speaks english with a really
thick
russian accent i don't know so it was
really weird i don't know if they made
it in english originally or
i don't know what they did was is they
tried to make a movie it was kind of
like the thing
and aliens and
in a doom movie all in one with zombie
kind of [ __ ]
i gotta say i liked the monster in this
it was a good idea and it's one
you don't really see a lot of um i guess
it's not too much to spoil it right
because it's kind of like i mean i know
it's new and everything but
it's on shutter by the way yeah did the
the um i wouldn't spoil that i don't
think
well what kind of mind what kind of
monster what kind of monster it is i
wouldn't really spoil it
i'm just going to say that
there's some big differences with this
move they did a lot of stuff right and
they did some stuff that was wrong
in the beginning they're kind of like in
a in in an arctic
type area in russia it's real cold
they're trying to give you
the feeling that it's very cold outside
and that they're doing paramilitary [ __ ]
it's kind of like something out of
aliens or something out of the thing
you're trying to get to this super deep
boring sight where there evidently some
kind of disease has has broken out and
um
or something's going on something's
going on
the main character is this woman who
she's like a virologist right
epidemiology epidemiologist right she's
studying epidemics
and um the military's taking her in
there there's some kind of soviet
soviet airborne infantry takes place in
1984. yeah
yeah it's it's happening in 84.
it look the the look is pretty good uh
in that in the opening scenes the
problem is
is that unlike
unlike the thing in the thing it really
did look like they were out in the cold
because they were
whenever they breathed there's [ __ ]
steam and fog coming out of their mouths
and not in this one there there's snow
but no fog
so it doesn't look real analog and i
think because of the dubbing
issues and also the way the story arc is
going in the very beginning there's too
many goddamn characters and too much
useless dialogue
you don't need to know very much they're
not it's not exposition it's just they
keep cramming a bunch of different
characters into this and it doesn't feel
very natural it feels unnatural
now when they get into the boresight
starts feeling a little bit better
starts feeling like something kind of
out of
aliens versus predator you know when
they go down in there and they find a
temple it's kind of like that in a way
but there's no temple
it's just and it's also kind of like uh
alien where they're in the alien ships
or you know how it's
it kind of looks like they're in a
spaceship but they're not they're
underwater or they're uh underground
this actually it's funny you mentioned
underwater because this gave me a little
bit of that kind of
movie vibe too a little bit yeah
underwater was a lot better though
it was the way it looked it looked a lot
better looked a lot more worn and lived
in this
kind of has a brand new and shiny kind
of feel to it in certain areas almost
kind of like a made for tv movie
where it doesn't really look like
they're in a lived in space oh yeah
yeah yeah i know what you're talking
about it doesn't really look like that
looks like a set um
it was the kind of situation where less
would have been more
i think that if they had i agree if
they'd had
fewer characters and more of a driving
story moving faster
you didn't need all that exposition yeah
something more straightforward because
like i said
i think at some point um you know after
they go down into the borehole
and i kind of lost track of because i
know there was the one
guy dr gregoriov or whatever his name
was and he was the only guy that had the
key
to the elevators right and he was the
only guy that knew the
code and then at some point he took off
and like took the key with him
and i didn't really i didn't get what
his motivation was like he was
why did he get them down there and then
leave them like oh now you're stuck down
here
like i think there was probably a reason
but i didn't catch it yeah they tend to
they because the way the writing and the
storytelling is they tend to make
big deals out of things that you don't
need to know and then
ignore things that maybe you should know
it's kind of an inverse
to it maybe have something to do with
russian storytelling maybe something was
edited out
it's just it feels like a very messy
script it should have been a lot tighter
um there's there's a bunch of [ __ ] we
didn't have to know but they spent time
on it you know uh they're trying to
characterize characters that aren't
really a big deal to begin with anyway
you notice you notice that there were
two characters they're trying to let you
to get to know these characters but
why well they're going to die well and
there were too many of them there are
too many of them right
yeah the thing about it is that and like
i said i mean we sound like we're
[ __ ] on it but this was actually
like a pretty good like an enjoyable
movie and i will say the monster like i
said i really i don't want to spoil it
because i just i find i i like that i
didn't know
what the monster or the baddie was when
i was going in and i will say the
special effects on it are
really good like once it gets to that
point and
the bad [ __ ] starts to happen and like
they do all that stuff the special
effects are really really
grody it um had a good score
that too yeah music it had what i guess
was kind of like some old
underground banned russian rock music
that was in
from the 80s that was in english maybe
it was a hit in in
over there you know i mean back in the
80s it doesn't sound good to us but
it was russian and then they did a bunch
of like soviet vaporwave where it kind
of yeah i dug that
yeah new wave
keyboard sounds but it was kind of like
vaporwave
or or new retro wave but it had kind of
like a soviet spin
or russian kind of sound to it
futuristic and
russian and that was really cool um so i
think they did well with the with the
with with the score um
the acting wasn't bad the casting wasn't
bad there's too many goddamn characters
i liked the woman that played like the
main
role she was the epidemiologist and so
like i said she gets
um she was involved in some kind of
similar project
earlier which is why they called her to
be like because i liked the
setup of this yeah because they were
kind of like look way down in this
deep [ __ ] hole um where they're
supposed to be like drilling for stuff
but they're like no actually of course
they're doing all kind of like secret
experimentation that they're not
supposed to be doing like
seven to eight miles below the earth
yeah and so they're like something bad's
happening down there they've evacuated
most of the people
but we keep hearing people like
screaming and moaning and stuff and a
bunch of people have gone missing and we
don't know what happened to them
so they call her and they get like a
whole bunch of like military guys
and they need to go down there and check
it out and figure out what's going on
because they think it's some kind of
diseases that's why they call her
it's the same setup as alien 2. pretty
much she's like
ripley the specialist in something she's
gone in with the military and some
military dudes and a couple technical
people
to go hook up with some basically the
lost colonists
some of them have doctors and [ __ ]
they're gonna be in there but it's that
same
setup kinda the difference is
is that even though aliens two had a
pretty big cast
most of the cast was very minimal it was
very trimmed down
it was more show than tell that's how
you got
to know the the marines you didn't have
to know them that much
you just showed them doing [ __ ] and
interacting with each other
this one's like almost a little bit too
much detail too much exposition you
don't need to know all that
not a lot it's just too much an 80s
version
action movie which this is kind of
homaging was if you go back and look at
the screenplay it's very trimmed
down there's not a lot there yeah i feel
like it would have benefited from you
didn't need um
quite all those military guys no you
didn't need like some of the subplots
there's like you know now we're going up
now we're going down now we're at the
because there's two levels i guess there
was a
level that was called the resort that
was that was where the living quarters
were for the people that worked there
and then the lowest level is called
sahara and that's where the labs were
and that's where the trouble was i think
but i think it became a little bit too
muddled
about when where they were in the
facility and which way they were going
and why they were going there
particularly
i think that was just like a little
muddled and like i said i thought that
um it needed to be shorter yeah like
they could have they should have focused
tighter on well you know we need to
figure out
what the hell because it felt like the
setup was really good like we there's
all this screaming and moaning 20 people
are missing
from this facility um you know and and
at the beginning when she first gets
there like in the helicopter
and that one guy comes staggering out
and blows himself up
and then she's like taking samples or
whatever and he's like seems to be
glowing and they're just like what the
[ __ ]
so that's the setup of it is great but
then i feel like for about 20 30 minutes
it kind of wanders around
yeah for a little while i noticed that
yeah and it kind of wanders around but
then
once that girl comes up that woman olga
i think her name was or whatever her
name was
when that woman comes in and they're
like how the [ __ ] did she even get in
here because the elevator was
not in the right place or whatever and
then when they see what
is going on with her like yeah i don't
want to spoil it like i said but what's
going on with her body let's call it
that
um then it kind of ramps back up and
then i was like okay and then like the
last part of it which i think you would
kind of dozed off by that point
but the last part of it when they
actually show what the deal is what the
deal is and what's going
on that was great like the special
effects were like so
goopy and just so so awesome yeah the
problem was
is in the screenplay and the writing
okay
like i said i'm going to go back to
aliens or alien 2.
if you looked at how that went it was
like sporadic
thing setups some action and then like
some more
action and then all of a sudden like a
cool down period where it gives the
audience a time to absorb what's
happening
and another set like like for instance
they're going to the med bay
hey look you know look at these [ __ ]
space huggers
well what's laying these eggs oh he
likes you you know this little [ __ ] like
that
it's just there was a time to absorb
what was happening
you know they were they were trying to
show the audience
um what the situation was and there
never was really any scenes like that
where you were being explained
obviously what the characters thought
was happening
or it it kept losing me
i mean there was muddled there was one
point where
she explained something about is this
like a spoiler
where she explains something about like
uh you know like ants
do you remember that part yeah yeah that
was the only thing that were you kind of
so that was
yeah so so like i said i felt like the
movie's kind of long like i said it's an
hour and 55 minutes and i feel like they
could have trimmed like 25 minutes off
of it
mostly from the first and second act
just like i said cut down
you don't even have to cut down there
weren't that many characters but i felt
like there were some that were extra
and they should have like cut a few of
them out and focused more on the ones
that
remained and then kept the story more
focused like
you know not where at the resort level
and then the doctor ran off with the key
and all this other stuff
it's basically just like get to the lab
and then something
bad is happening in the lab and then you
trying to figure out what it is
and trying to escape the monster it
should have like
tightened up the focus some but it's not
a bad movie by any means no
and there's some subplots that just
don't need to be no they don't need to
be there like one of the guys
i guess he's kind of like a scientist is
in always fighting with one of the dudes
who's in
who's the spats not dude or airborne guy
they always like
have to almost get in the damn piss and
match in a fight match all the time
he didn't really need that there's just
there was just a little bit too much
stuff happening like you said it
muddled the story but i think there was
like a really good
you know if you took some stuff out i
didn't think you'd have to like redo
because the special effects are amazing
you have to reshoot anything you just no
you wouldn't
yeah just take some [ __ ] out yeah and
just and just tighten the focus up and
like i said
the special effects i think were my
favorite part of this like in the third
act like when it just went
bat [ __ ] crazy like once that girl
arrived and then like
the bad [ __ ] started happening that was
that was great like the it was
looked really good i got cut 15 to 20
minutes of fat out of this movie
yeah and it would probably play a lot
better at least to an american audience
maybe this is just the way russians like
stories told i don't know esther asked
if it was similar to the crazies
it is a similar kind of premise that's
the george romero one they remade it i
think in the 2000s but the
i don't think i saw the remake i like
their original though
that was from the 73 it's a similar
premise it's more kind of like like you
said it's kind of like more like along
the lines of aliens or the thing
right or something like that and like i
said it gave me a little bit of an
underwater
vibe yeah um not exactly the same
because that was kind of like
that was more cut that's almost kind of
more cosmic horror
yeah underwater was like something out
of aliens so like something out of yeah
it's almost kind of like a um
that movie got [ __ ] on all right but
underwater has built a good
um um cult following that's a very high
quality movie well i feel like after it
came out it's almost like a few months
later everybody saw it and then they
were like oh hey this is good
it was very good i think everybody just
assumed it wasn't going to be good
because
uh it came out in january so everybody
just assumes a horror movie that comes
out in january is automatically going to
suck well it's also kind of
you know this [ __ ] happening under
waters and so there's been some [ __ ]
bad sci-fi movies that have happened
yeah so you can't
like blame people for you know because
they've been burned before i put it up
i put it up there with you know 81 alien
2
blade runner prometheus you know it's
like something ridley scott would have
made
but you know there's a cthulhu in it
yeah and you go [ __ ] this one this is a
different this one is still
cosmic horror in a sense well not really
this one is more
scientific horror like it's not this
isn't supernatural
well i guess underwater wasn't really
supernatural because because you could
absolutely well okay it's just deep sea
monster cthulhu exists
yeah cthulhu was arrested but this one
is less like that this one is more
uh kind of to an extent something that
could happen
although it goes kind of crazy at the
end and it's like i'm not sure if that
could happen
um but maybe sort of uh esther
asked or no um tammy asked did you say
where it's streaming
and then esther said it's on amazon
prime it's on shutter as well
it's on shutter as well so if you have
shutter you can watch it on there at
least in the us
not a bad movie i'm not you know i'm not
don't mean to [ __ ] on it just cr
critiquing it it's pretty good it's
worth watching it
like i said the effects are the best
part yeah um
i just feel like it could have been
shorter yeah that's i think that was the
only issue was the other
shorter edit and the dubbing was strange
yeah but i'm not going to shut down too
much because of that because
i'm just not sure what they were going i
mean dubbing just gets on my nerves
anyway because it's so distracting
but everybody wasn't dubbed in this i
don't think
it didn't seem like everyone was dubbed
because the main actress she didn't seem
that didn't seem like she was dubbed i
think you know i would
i would recommend underwater over this
and of course i would recommend the
thing over this
but similar if you like those two movies
you might like this one yeah you might
want to check this one out because it
was like it was decent
yeah and it made me learn something new
i didn't know that there was really a
cola super deep barrel
yeah super deep more hole i can't
believe that's what it's called
i just kind of clicked on it because
there's a like an extensive actually
wikipedia page for this movie where the
where the plot
is laid out in excruciating detail
um so and then i was like what this is
based on a real thing what and so like i
went to another you know you get on the
wikipedia [ __ ] rabbit hole yeah see
khan says
underwater was badass i liked underwater
man i liked it just as good as [ __ ]
ridley scott movies you know
really scott like i said you know
blade runner and it's like it came out
of the damn ridley scott universe
and yeah the quality of of the
production was right there with the
ridley scott type stuff
i got it sitting right next to all my
ridley scott stuff and the damn
has a priority
i think they made two versions of this
movie russian and english in some parts
that might explain it because some of
the people are definitely not dubbed
like she is not dubbed you can tell
that's her real voice and she's really
talking
but some of the other people you know
you can tell because like the
the thing doesn't quite match up but
they look like they're speaking english
but then the dubbing is doesn't have a
russian accent that might
that might explain why it kind of has an
artificial feel to me
you know what i mean but i get what
you're saying it does the well the way
it's shot
i kind of feel like when you do movies
like this like underwater did and stuff
like that i felt like this needed
moodier
lighting yeah and make the place make it
look dirtier yeah it didn't look dirty
and lived it as much it looked it looked
like something that i don't know deep
space
nine that's what i was gonna say it gave
me like kind of a star trek
kind of look to it where everything was
kind of like clean yeah and new
which maybe it would have been uh
because you know i guess
in the universe of this movie it hadn't
been there that long so it wasn't like
you know i think they were trying to
homage alien and alien too though
probably yeah that place looked like
hadley's hope or it looked like inside
the nostromo
yeah that's true yeah so but it just it
didn't look
worn yeah yeah and there was something
about
not i don't know like something about
the cinematography or like i said the
lighting i think it just needed to be
like have
moodier lighting i guess but you know i
could see what they were going for but
there were some parts of it that were
dark and when they got to the like the
part where the monsters were then it was
you know ever they were all kind of like
alarms and [ __ ] going off so it's like a
lot of the lights had gone out so
everything was like red
um so that was cool but and and i really
liked
there was one scene toward the very end
where she has to go
outside of the facility for a short time
uh to get something and i guess it's
like 200 degrees out there because it's
like you know
seven eight miles uh under the earth and
uh
that part and she sees like i said what
what the monster is kind of but um she
kind of sees this big thing and that was
like a really cool scene i liked that a
lot
you know when she's out there kind of
getting cooked or whatever so that was
kind of that was cool i like that
but yeah it's overall it's like it was a
good movie i just feel like it should
have been shorter that's all
yeah but it was a good idea the special
effects looked fantastic i thought
were really gross and goopy uh which you
know i like that yeah that
was one of the strong points that
creature effects looked pretty good
yeah i thought it looked really good and
it was like a couple scenes like one
toward the end like in the elevator when
sushi was going back up and stuff like
that with like i said i can't spoil it
because you can't
they had some body horror stuff going on
it was very yeah it's very very body
hard it was effective
yeah it's kind of stuff to where they
could you know you could do a sequel on
this movie
but like i said i'd tighten that script
up a lot yeah i think that's the only
criticism you can make of it really
the main christian it needs a tighter
just needed to be edited
yeah but that's all yeah um you know i'm
not bothered
but yeah so in case i didn't mention it
the director's name is arsenii
sorry i'm sure i'm butchering that i
can't say russian names might be his
first movie i'm not entirely sure
maybe not i don't know but you know
did you know that the cola super deep
borehole existed
ah [ __ ] sounds x-rated that's what i
thought
[Laughter]
yeah we should totally start our own
porn company starring johnny bedrock
johnny bedrock yeah everybody that's in
the movies has to have a porn name that
has to do with like
digging deep into the earth
it's mick manhole
[Laughter]
i just i don't know
all right so uh oh conovazon said jenny
did you like sputnik more
yeah i think i did uh i liked sputnik
quite a lot actually
that was the other russian one that we
saw yeah i think sputnik was a little
bit better it was a little bit better
that's because then i say it was because
they had it
sputnik had a tighter at it yeah it was
much shorter yeah
um it was easier to understand had less
had a smaller cast
there's too many goddamn people in this
movie
too many notes to be goddamn people well
some of the
some of the feelings of fear go away
when you're when there's a crowd of damn
people
that's true you know what's going to
threaten the crowd of people [ __ ]
godzilla
we got 100 dudes standing here man i'm
scared to go down there
you know well yeah that's the thing if
you're going down and like you think
maybe there's a monster or something
scary it's like well they'll probably
eat all these people and i'll have time
to run away yeah
well it's harder to be scared in a
massive group because everybody's
[ __ ] equally [ __ ] suffering
together that's that's all true you know
[ __ ] guys who survived [ __ ]
military [ __ ] just
massacres where their units were getting
wiped out a lot of them weren't scared
because
they were seeing people die and but they
were all their friends dying and they
figured well i'm just gonna be killed
along with everybody else
so it's kind of like you can you can
accept your inevitable death a lot
better because
you're not alone yeah yeah i think we're
all going out together
i think that's what makes people afraid
is more being by yourself
yeah more than being in a group yeah
yeah i totally get that yeah i totally
got that because i could
and other people can like relate to the
same [ __ ] because everybody's going
through everybody's going to die so
we're all going to die together
yeah i get it yeah suffering and
suffering in a massive group is a lot
easier
yeah then [ __ ] by yourself that's why
when you capture prisoners the first
thing you do is separate them
one so they can't cook up a story and
other ones is it demoralizes them
yeah they can't get gang up on you yeah
yeah well yeah that's everybody
damn that's just uh psychology 101 yeah
but yeah so like i said shutter amazon
prime if you want to watch it st
it's decent uh just i mean really just
for the creature effects alone i thought
i thought they were just
they were so so good and i really liked
like some of the imagery like
later on like i said i don't want to
spoil it but you know what i mean um i
was going to say something else and i
can't remember what it was ah [ __ ] well
all right i don't know but i think i
think what it was because remember i
told you last night there's another
movie that's on shutter i think it's
brazilian
and it's called skull colon the mask
and i read i remember reading about it a
while back
and i was like man that sounds fun i was
like that sounds like super gory and
over the top like it sounds like
something you would like and plus it's
brazilian
and uh that when i when i went to watch
it back then because i heard about it a
few months ago
um i couldn't find it anywhere but
shutter just added it
like a week or two ago so maybe we'll
watch that tonight let's see if that's
any good khan brings up a good one
he says we haven't we haven't reviewed
without warning
uh what i saw without warning when i was
a kid i remember when it came out yeah
i loved it uh wouldn't mind seeing it
again i should write that down actually
that movie
inspired some guys to write another
movie
that they thought was a better version
of that and it was called predator one
yeah yeah without warning was the
inspiration for them to write predator
yeah and it was some army guys wrote
predator
and put it underneath the [ __ ] door
and [ __ ] they gave the script away
for free
and that's that's so awesome this is so
awesome you can [ __ ] have it they're
like this is great
the present for you yeah yeah it was
basically like without warning but with
in a military setting yeah because i
think when we reviewed predator i think
we mentioned that
yeah um but yeah i think i saw it but it
was so long ago that i could barely
exactly pounce was in that one did he
play this is he
i think he i think jack pounces in he
played the drunk that saw the alien did
he have any styrofoam fall on his head i
don't think so
i think he's just leaving that damn
shape hopefully someone knows what i'm
talking about
[Laughter]
yeah jack pounce getting [ __ ] killed
in an
he was in a lot of really shitty he was
in some really bad like sword and
sorcery type movies like in the 80s um
particularly they did one on uh mystery
science theater what the [ __ ] was the
name of that thing where he played a
wizard with a ridiculous hat
i don't know and it was just oh my god
it's so so [ __ ] fun that was that was
[ __ ]
in jack powell's decline when he would
just yeah i could work with
he just wanted a check he's like look i
just want some booze and drugs
can i please just have some money yeah
[Laughter]
i guess pounds it kind of worn out
without his welcome
so he ended up having to be like a
c-lister yeah
it was it was kind of sad to see but
yeah it's sad because he had a lot of
gravitas
to him but then i think didn't he have
like kind of a comeback later because he
did
he ended like [ __ ] what was that
movie with he came back later
yeah he came back later and got like i
remember him doing the push-ups at the
oscars or whatever
yeah louie says check out a movie called
hold the dark which is pretty good i've
heard that was good yeah that's on
netflix so i will have to uh
watch that as well but yeah so what do
we
gore there you go yeah outlaw of gore i
think yeah it's just called
outlaw or outlaw of gore yeah uh
yeah that was a [ __ ] terrible ass
movie but it's supposedly based on
a series of books which are i guess are
not bad but
i this it's one of my favorite mystery
science theater episodes joe because the
movie is just so [ __ ] ridiculous
that it's just it's it's hilarious the
dude's sidekick
and like the [ __ ] if it's so 80s
everyone has like that big hair and like
that
aerobic spandex with like those super
high
like [ __ ] aerobic clothes and [ __ ]
it's like so [ __ ] funny everything's
power rangers like proto power rangers
really the [ __ ] they would wear
yeah like jogging suits yep city
slickers that's what i was thinking yeah
he was in city slickers later on
uh okay so i guess we're gonna wrap it
up right yeah all right so
you sleepy again even though we did
actually kind of get some
sleep although we woke up early this
morning but i always wake up early all
right so
we will be back tomorrow talking about
whatever movie we decide to watch
this evening so have a good rest of your
day you guys
thanks for dropping by we will see you
guys tomorrow afternoon